Many of you are getting distracted because you don't have something that's totally
Detached it
If you won't get to the next level
You're gonna have to give up something right shut the TV down listen to me put the controller down
Want to soar get a mentor what's up believe nation its Evan
This channel is designed to be a part of your daily success routine and help you believe in your Michael Jordan level talent
so today we're gonna learn from one of the best Eric Thomas and how to develop discipline and achieve your
Dreams mentor me Eric. Also, if you want to know what Eric and other entrepreneurs have to say about building unstoppable confidence
Check out my 250 for confidence series where every day for the next
254 days. I will send you a morning video for free helping you build your confidence
The link is in the description below. I have boundaries. You've got to make a sacrifice
If you don't get to the next level, you're gonna have to give up something get that gold get that dream
And I'm just been telling you driving and driving and driving and driving. What I've been talking about is consistency
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one have a strong why I got an older white male keep probably in his sixties maybe
Right and my man says to me, you know, like I heard what you say et. But how do you sustain it?
I'm like, okay. I'm like I said hinted only make sure I'm hearing what you're saying you like you talk about
120 you talking about going harm you talk about having what you want being what you want. Do what you want
Okay, I get it. But how do you sustain it? I'm thinking is there real question? I said listen to me very closely
How did I start this whole presentation off he said write down the people name and she loved I said dumb if you waking up
Every day and think about your wife
Uh, how do you not sustain it if you wake up every day and you're looking at your son?
How do you not sustain it? You think I'm gonna put my kid's life in a hand some other man
Do you think that's my role as a father?
Do you think my role is to allow my kids?
To come here and pay all this money go to school and do everything they did
And now they gotta go beg somebody else for a job. That's not my role or responsibility
To sustain it. What do you mean? How do you not sustain?
You why are you not pumped up? Why you have days up I'm asking you why you get 70% you'll love nobody
Is there not somebody that you don't love more than yourself is
There's not somebody you waking up for is it's not somebody is grinding for somebody told me that they get distracted easy
Let me tell you something. The reason why you didn't distract me because you
You wake up to every single dance
I gotta go many of you are getting distracted because you don't have something that's over to the detachment
You need something stronger than the distraction you
Get distracted with parties you get distracted with spoken you get distracted with drinking you getting distracted with sleeping you getting distracted with video
Games Wow, because the video game is stronger than your goal. So my homies all the time bro. Didn't got to do it
Y'all be playing. I'm like forget about the money
You're just singing it. I'm for real. Don't probably blow me off
rule number two be strategic
All right. Let's be honest how many y'all get up and you just get your day started?
You don't have it written down. You won't have a strategy you don't have a real plan
You kind of just get up and say I'm about to tackle today raise your hand for me raise your hand
We're gonna stop no more that like you don't go to war without a plan. You just don't come out Digitas
I hope I hit somebody
I told y'all we know there are no sorting stuff. That is it. I'll be back this with the wheel
He's just blowing up stuff. We're on that Jason Bourne
You're going to the top floor
That we got that scope
I'm being 100. We know II just get up in the woods. This is about it somebody in attendance
You didn't throw up your whole house. I
Mean you got my man with you to throw the whole house up
Got some other people in the mending process you mean he barely got here me to kill up a little dust strategy open up
So fucking late in a couple hours
Mission accomplished you move on I need you to be strategic
I can't look at I want to go to the NBA not like that
You just running up and down the court not like that. You're not going
No strategy. I want to go through there fail. You ain't even in school
You know, you're not going to the NFL. I want to make millions
You're not even doing what millionaires do and there's those of you you messed up
Why because you're not you don't understand think act eat rest. So what are we talking about?
We're talking about a schedule. I realized that my strength is in my routine
Why because I'm not as strong as I thought
That was I'm not as intelligent as I thought I was I don't want it as bad as I thought I wanted it
It's my routine. It's what I do every day
Repeatedly, I just help somebody out you're struggling because you don't have any change you all
thought that
You finally got my man. I have to pull out that but you messed up everything else in your life
You lost all your friends cuz you do have a schedule the DNA of your success is in your routine
You not as deep as you think you are, you gotta find a routine getting up at 3:00 and stick with it
I'm getting up at 5:00 and stick with it. Yeah out of 365 days
You have a bad dare - what?
I'm trying to tell you the the strength is in the routine find a routine and stick with it rule number three
make sacrifices
your girl gonna be like your win spending time together like your girl bone test you your man gonna test you like you like I
Want to be a lawyer I want to be a doctor
I wanna you know
I want to be an engineer you study and I gotta focus your mom's gonna be a hurt your family gonna think you you know
You better than everybody else. Your people don't challenge you like. Where are you?
Like you too good for us, but I'm trying to tell you number three you got to make a sacrifice
If you're gonna get to the next level
You're gonna have to give up something, right?
You're gonna have to give up
Something and I'm just gonna keep it real with y'all when I say give up when I talk about sacrifice
I'm saying give up your current blessings like it's gonna be hard
Give up the current blessings. Are you hear what I'm telling you?
I had to make a sacrifice and so what I mean by sacrifice again is giving up that which is in your hand
Giving that thing up
that's like right in your hand that the thing that you can see that you can touch that you can take like the thing that
you holding on to
Risking everything I have now for what could be are you here to me?
That's tough. And for an entire year. I wasn't answering the phone like that
Y'all I was I wasn't I wasn't doing the entertainment thing
I wasn't going out like that on the weekends with my girl like that
I wasn't spending as much time as I would like to with my family or my are you what I'm telling you?
Number three is gonna be the most important one, you know, write it down shut it down
Yup
But that might last for about two weeks before
You start getting to you like it might last a month 30 days before it starts getting to you when people start walking like Joe
Life cuz people start calling you out. Right and you start losing stuff to gang stuff. Listen to me
I'm talking to somebody you're ready to give up
You're ready to give up on break as good as telling you buy and I'm telling you to look good in the face
Look good in the face and say bye. Bye
Look look as the opportunities you have now and say bye bye that old so you can get greater opportunities. Are you hearing me?
It's gonna take a sacrifice and everybody talks that talks everybody talk about going to the next level
Everybody talk about next level living everybody wearing a t-shirt
Everybody's talking it and - it's time to pay up and when it's time to pay
Their people who not willing to pay you gonna have to sacrifice some bleep to get this one. Yep
You can't get up at the same time you go ahead to sacrifice some friendship to get to this one
You gonna have to sacrifice some entertainment to get to this one and the only way you cling to yourself that you really want
when you really want it is that you no longer hit the snooze buttons you no longer you no longer lose focus when you're studying
You no longer take shortcuts you no longer playing games
You are willing to do whatever it takes whatever it takes I'll do whatever it takes to get to that milestone
And if you don't have that in you this year, baby, I'm telling you. Don't be stuck on average
It's a great without making a great sacrifice it's your boy et sense if it was easy to do
Yeah, if it was easy to hit milestones, everybody would be hitting them every single day. It ain't easy
But it's doable
But only to those who are willing to give up
To go up and you got to ask yourself this question
Are you really really really really ready to make the sacrifices necessary?
To get to the next level and that answer is yes
But I guarantee you I guarantee you it's only a matter of time before that dream is no longer dream
But you are living in that reality
So do me a favor make the sacrifice so that you can make the rest of your life
The best of your life you'll number 4 change your mindset. It's a whole mental when people don't get it
Everybody wants to say okay. We're here go 10 steps to okay. Lewis said do 8 et said do 9
You know this person says this to 12 steps and everybody's trying to get two steps without the mentality
It's like, okay, maybe you don't need all nine, or maybe you don't need all eight. Maybe need four. Maybe you need 12
I don't know but I think sometimes they see what we do and say if I can if if like if I can duplicate that
Just like exactly how he does in the book exactly and it's like, you know, you have a story
You know you you having a unique experience and so you're 12 are shaped by by not just your world
But how your world has shaped your thinking and I think that's the part that missions like guys, you know
If it was easy, everybody could do it if it was a cookie cutter. Everybody would just follow it to the tee
But there's a mindset and when I looked at Serena, you know when I look at the Michael Jordan's already Tom Brady
You know you look at Michael Phelps like it is a mentality
You know on our new album the resolution I talk about I got that dog, and I'm not really referring to just this, you know
Aggressiveness but it is a mindset. I saw Belichick said something where you never like how you feeling about the super boys
I'm gonna be honest with you with five weeks behind
He's like everybody else next year next year - is practicing training they lost
You know they and so they're trying to get ready lifting weights. They're reading book. They're you know, everybody that lost the study
He's like, yeah, we found what type of mine
Tracy five weeks behind in super well, but again
It's a mentality and I think a lot of people are missing that mentality rule number five work on your focus
I want you to see difficult differently. Are you hearing me? I need you to see
Difficult differently now now that weight lifter when my man looking at those weights when he got that iron that iron is heavy
But he's not looking at that. I like look how heavy the iron is and he knows what it's gonna do
It's gonna tear his muscles to pieces he gets it but what he understands is that if he tears them down
They go rebuild themselves and when they rebuild themselves, they're that much stronger
Listen to me the more you go through the more difficult. It is the more challenging
It is listen to me the harder it is. Are you hearing me the more challenging?
It is all you're doing baby is building my soul. You're building muscle. So don't quit don't give up
Don't know stare it listen to me. You don't get bumped by staring at weights
you don't get bumped by by look you don't get healthier by staring at it you get healthier by running up to it and
Grabbing it and pushing it look push through that stuff push through it. You can get through it
He said he won't put on you more than you can bear
You can get through it and rule number six the last one
We put a very special bonus clip is shut it all down and listen. Let me just explain something to y'all
I gotta keep it watered. CJ twelve years younger than me
I was out of high school before this boy was even really born. Are you hear what I'm saying?
My man 12 years younger than me
Twelve years and he picked up that phone and yet oh he had one of them heart to heart
Do you have anybody in your inner circle that's willing to be real with you that's willing to keep it
100 that don't care none about your feelings, but they care about your goals and your dreams
CJ hit me up. I called my man left for message. Like see they killing me
They want to know when the mixtape coming out. When is the next mixtape coming out? See see set et?
Let me tell you something shut it
I said what he said shut it down shut the television ain't no mixtape coming stop doing TG
I shut it down. That's why you got the reruns for so long. He said shut it down. He shut it down
I'm tired. He said we'll keep it. Well, I'm tired eat the last true mixtape you was talking about how you gonna get your PhD
Between me and you amano he model man
The man we will not come out with another mixtape were you talking about what you gonna do?
Shut it all down eat. Do you understand that that the future of this company is on you finishing his ph.d
Shut the gigs now
shut it down and I'm telling y'all one of the bay up one of the ways your boy got the
Milestone up. I had to shut it down. I said down the phone called flat out from a certain time
Don't call my house. If you love me. Text me if you love me and they ain't no emergency
Don't go I had to shut it down shut the TV down
Listen to me put the controllers down shut down born out sole it on the weekend go to the club
Look, shut it down shut down your favorite team. Stop watching your favorite football or basketball or Sox, whatever it is
Shut it down and I'm telling you you ain't gotta set it down for the rest of your life
But you gotta set it down long enough so you can get shows through ball zone
Yeah, so you can get your NBA Finals done. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, so you get your World Series done. Yep
Are you hearing so you don't national titles? Oh, are you hearing me so you can get joke book done
So you just chose CDs finished so you can get your degree so you can take your mirrors to the next level shut it down
I had to suck the noise down
I had to shut it down when I shut it down when I set certain things down in my life
Boom, I went through a whole of the level now
I've got a really special bonus cut from Eric on how to
Discipline yourself that I think you're gonna really enjoy but before that it's time for the three-point landing questions tying the move from just watching
Another video to actually taking action in your business. So answer these three questions number one
What is your strong line number two?
What is preventing you from being focused and water gonna do about it number three?
What is the biggest mindset shift that you need to make right now?
I was like, yo, you got to discipline yourself. I started looking at mother Teresa of
Gandhi and I was like yo, bro Gandhi would go fast from sex and he was married he would fast from talking
You know
I just start watching these great people's like all these people fast and not about fast and like that's not the peace
but they were very disciplined people and they would not allow their exterior world to dominate or
Destroy their internal world. I just like you I want to get to a place where I can control me
My family members have grown
I lost two uncles cirrhosis of the liver brilliant man, but just drinking drinking drinking and I was like yo
I do not want to my father was a substance abuser for years
I was like, yo, I don't want a life where something else is controlling me
You know like for when I left home and said I don't want to be controlled no more
Like I meant that like, I don't know nothing to control me, but me and so I got to put myself under extreme
Discipline to make sure I'm free. So when people see me you get up at 3:00. You don't drink you don't smoke
I'm not doing that because I think I'm better than a BYOs
Oh
I think you gonna go to hell because you had a drink I just want I want to control I want freedom and for me
disciplining myself
means more freedom and unless I you discipline yourself people who I
Told my son other dads like your son. I don't not want you to have fun
I've just seen a history of people who just have fun Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween know
There are the people learns that night
Every night there are the people who end up in a 20s having a great deal of fun
But in a 40s and 50s they working for somebody
And I'm not saying nothing wrong with cleaning toilets
But they doing something I want to do for the rest of a life and they can't retire because they played so much
You know, so for me
I just look at Venus and Serena Michael Jackson when he used to like five and six just dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline himself
The greater don't mean it's gonna happen
But the greater the probability that he has this sense of freedom raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value
is that we believe that people have passion and
Change the way people
Not one drop of myself work depends on your it's suppose to mean
If you want to learn how to be more disciplined I highly recommend checking out my one rule video on being disciplined
The link is right next to me continue to believe and I'll see you there
just one discipline discipline discipline discipline discipline discipline discipline discipline discipline